another major article has been written
about YouTube's ad pocalypse and
specifically about the david pakman show
youtube channel so the background on ad
pocalypse dates back to a long time ago
in what feels like a galaxy far away
although it was really actually here in
the studio March 31st of 2017 where
YouTube in response to very hyperbolic
concerns put out there by The Wall
Street Journal and a few other corporate
media outlets about YouTube ads showing
up on racist or extremist content on
YouTube YouTube turned on a new ad
algorithm which instantly overnight
eliminated 99 percent of our YouTube
revenue now fortunately since then I've
told you that about a third to 30 35 33
35 37 % of our YouTube revenue has come
back the New York Times wrote a major
article about our YouTube channel during
our April vacation very good article one
might say a tremendous article the best
article in some sense and now a wired
article has been written about what's
going on with our YouTube channel really
good article I was interviewed for it
and I want to read to you just a little
bit of what this article says which will
sort of get us up to speed on what's
going on and I think it was a really
well-done piece the article says quote
in 2009 David Pakman started the David
Pakman show on YouTube to talk
progressive politics over the years his
audience grew as did his earnings today
he has about three hundred and
sixty-five thousand followers who watch
enough ads to fund his show at least
they did but when YouTube started
expanding protections for advertisers to
keep their ads from showing up alongside
controversial content the money dried up
by the end of March Pakman says he saw a
96 percent drop in ad revenue compared
to what he was making on average during
the six previous months about a month
later things bounce back but not by much
nowadays Pakman makes just a little more
than one-third of what he used to on his
channel quote if you're seeing
fluctuations in your revenue over the
next few weeks it may be because we're
fine-tuning our ad system to address
these concerns a YouTube community
manager post from March says the post
also gives youtubers instructions on how
to submit an appeal to YouTube
they think their videos lost ad revenue
by mistake yeah big mistake that took
place there right one other piece of
this article in Wired about the David
Pakman show YouTube channel says but
there could be another way when Pakman
saw his first drop in revenue he set up
a crowdfunding page on patreon which let
his fans pledge a small monthly fee to
support the show Jacqueline said this
added revenue stream helps cover the
costs of paying his small staff and kept
the show afloat when YouTube's ad
revenue dried up so what is the status
today the status is similar to what this
article said on Wired just a couple of
days ago we've got about a third to 37%
of our revenue we had a sort of glitch
in the system last week on the bonus
show we did a story Pat about how a porn
star is getting sued for having taken
and published a picture of a 70 year old
woman in a locker room we didn't do that
story on the regular show we did that
story on the bonus show however some of
our YouTube video descriptions mentioned
that the bonus show that day had a story
about a porn star being sued the mere
appearance of the word porn is what
caused the chaos with last week's videos
being monetized that is how hanging by a
thread this entire situation is last
week we also did a story about how
Anonymous is using gay porn to hack into
Isis accounts indeed and I'm sure that
YouTube was not too happy about that
exactly no and clear what our position
on that is and it was completely work
safe no uh you know gory or obscene
pictures or anything like that no
swearing or anything like that so there
are basically five ways that you can
help to support our show and push push
back against what's going on on YouTube
but number one membership you can sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership
if you want a 40 percent discount you
can use the code I voted 17 number to
make a pledge at patreon.com slash david
pakman show even if it's only $1 a month
you can do that at patreon.com slash
david pakman show number three if you
ever shop on amazon.com go to david
pakman.com slash amazon before you shop
number four if you have youtube red
which is ten bucks a month to watch
youtube ad free
watch our videos because we get a cut of
that $10 fee and number five get your
gear this includes david pakman show
coffee bumper stickers and apparel at
david pakman.com slash gear good news on
patreon patreon donors are accumulating
fifteen hundred and thirty eight patrons
as of this morning it is a cumulative
process so everybody that can cover just
a dollar is more than making up for the
lost revenue on youtube because we
estimated we were making thirty to fifty
cents max from each Youtube subscriber
if they watched all hundred and sixty of
our monthly videos if you can do just a
doll or a month you're basically
covering yourself and one other person
and also good news when it comes to
membership people continue to sign up in
significantly increased numbers at david
pakman.com slash membership of course to
get that 40% discount select your
membership click the red sign up button
and then on the second page you will see
the field that says coupon code you can
type in I voted 17 there all right so
that's the latest update I'm trying to
only do an update on this like once
every couple weeks I want to remind you
it's still a problem but not spend the
entire show talking about ad pocalypse